[MUSIC PLAYING]
Happy Thursday,
everybody, and welcome
to the Data Science Hangout.
I hope everybody is
having a great week.
If we haven't had a chance
to meet yet, I'm Rachael.
It's so nice to meet you.
If it is your first time
joining us at the Hangout,
let us know in the chat so we
can all welcome you in as well.
This is our open space to chat
about data-science leadership,
questions you're
facing, and getting
to hear about what's going
on in the world of data
across different industries.
So every week, we get to feature
a different data-science leader
as my co-host here to help
lead our discussion and answer
questions from you all.
And so together, we're
all dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everybody.
And I'd love to hear
from everyone, no matter
your level of experience or
area of work or background.
It's also totally OK to
just listen in if you want.
There's also three ways to
ask questions and provide
your own perspective
on certain topics, too.
So you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom.
You could put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put
a little star next to it
if you're in a coffee
shop or something,
or your dog is barking, and
you want me to read it instead.
We also have a Slido link, which
my colleagues will share here
in the chat in just a
second, where you can also
ask questions anonymously.
We do share the
recordings of each session
up to the Posit YouTube
and the Hangout site.
So you can always go back and
rewatch or share with a friend.
But with all that, thank
you all for joining us again
this Thursday.
And thank you so much, Art,
for joining us as the co-host.
Art is a private investor
and former chairman, CEO,
and president of
OppenheimerFunds.
And Art, I'd love
to kick things off
with having you
introduce yourself,
maybe sharing a bit about your
journey, and also something
you like to do
outside of work, too.
Sure, sure.
Well, thanks very
much for inviting me.
I'm speaking to you all from
New York City, where we have yet
to see winter start.
Supposedly, we might get
some snow this weekend,
but we haven't had any
snow at all this winter.
So that's strange.
I'm sitting here in my
study, and I'm drinking out
of my ggplot mug, which--
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Nice.
ART STEINMETZ: --was designed
by [? Selena ?] Carter.
She graciously let me
put this design on--
what is one of those
sites that lets
you print out your own
T-shirts and stuff like that.
So I had myself a coffee
mug made with that.
Anyway, so I'm
technically retired.
I used to work on Wall Street.
I was a money manager
for most of my time,
before I went into a leadership
position at OppenheimerFunds.
And then I stepped down when
we sold the company to Invesco
back in 2019.
Since then, I've been involved
in a lot of this and that,
board work, philanthropic work.
But what I love most is being
a data-science hobbyist.
So I started working with R,
the language, back in 2006,
I think it was.
And it just grew from there.
And I've just really enjoyed
being able to use it first
in my professional work, and
then now more as a hobbyist,
and, as part of
that, really enjoyed
becoming part of the
R community and really
appreciating the joys
of open-source software
and its ability to put
power into people's hands
to really get good work
done to do good analysis.
Like anything else,
you can do lousy work.
[LAUGHS] And it's--
as we've seen with
ChatGPT, which
speaks very authoritatively and
confidently but sometimes spews
nonsense, it's certainly
dangerous to put
beautiful charts and
graphs into people's hands
that tell the wrong story.
And I think that's an
important narrative
around how open-source
propagates around
in organizations.
That's a cautionary lesson.
But anyway, we can talk
a little bit about that.
So anyway, that's what I do now.
You can see my blog at
ArtSteinmetz.com, where I share
my data-science experiments.
And I have to stress, I'm not
a data-science professional,
right?
I'm an investment professional.
So I am very much an
amateur, with all the caveats
that that implies.
But again, I really
enjoy hanging out
with smart people
like you folks,
who are in the
main-- actual data
scientists or actual
practitioners, professionally.
So Rachael said, so what do
you do for fun or something
outside of work?
Well, again, since
I'm retired, I
spend a lot of my time
playing around with R
while I'm sitting at my desk.
I like to ski.
I like to hike.
I was a home brewer.
I retired from that when
I moved from New Jersey
back into New York City.
But I can talk at length
about IPA recipes,
if anybody wants to do that.
But again, one of
the things that
is nice about playing around
with open-source software
is, it's not an expensive hobby.
Guys are famous for spending
enormous amounts of money
to buy gear for their hobbies,
whether it's fishing or cars
or whatever.
Fortunately, open-source
software is--
whatever I can come up
with, build in my head,
is what I'm spending money on.
So anyway, that's
enough about me.
I love it.
[CHUCKLES] I know the
mountains are getting a lot
of snow hopefully this weekend.
Are you going to
head out skiing?
Yeah, well, I was
in Big Sky, Montana
at the beginning of January.
And at 64 years old,
I probably shouldn't
do the double black diamonds.
But I went down one
that had thin cover.
And I hooked my armpit around a
tree stump, and I tore my pec.
So I had orthopedic
surgery a couple weeks ago.
So I've got to keep--
stay in a sling for
another few weeks.
But hopefully I'm going to get
a little late-season skiing
in this year when I go back
out, and hopefully won't do it
again--
tear myself up again.
Oh, wow.
Well, I hope you're
feeling OK now.
So I know, when we were talking
yesterday a little bit, Art,
you were mentioning, your
journey into data science
started when you became
a little bit frustrated
by the limits of Excel.
And I'm just curious to hear
about how that journey first
started and any tips
you have for people
who are also trying
to help others
in their organization
who'd love to learn, too.
Yeah, and the
disclaimer here is partly,
say, it was a
different time then.
A lot of times, when we
talk about cultural issues,
we talk about, well, it
was different back then.
And it was different back
then for data science
because back then,
employees at my firm
couldn't install any software
they pleased on their computer.
And that has--
certainly not true
in any responsible
organization today.
But it was a different time.
So even though I could
have put in the budget
request for Matlab, I'm
just inherently cheap.
And so when I learned about R,
I was really interested in that.
But I had become frustrated
with the limitations of Excel.
Playing around with-- like
spreadsheet geeks will do,
I had these giant
spreadsheets, and they
had a lot of VBA
macros, Visual Basic
macros, involved with them.
But they were increasingly
difficult to maintain.
And I would go back
and pull up a project
I had worked on
several months earlier
and was not able to figure
out what the heck I was doing
or what I was trying to
accomplish in that thing.
Or if I said, well, oh,
I can use my former work
because now this new
project I'm working on
is kind of like that, so let
me reuse some of my old work,
figuring out what
I did back then--
what former me had done-- just
was a huge pain in the neck.
So I was frustrated by that.
That was probably my
biggest frustration.
And in addition, just
the power of Excel,
when working on large data
sets with lots of computations,
was also not--
I was running up against
the limitations there.
But again, this was just me.
There was nothing I would
say I was in production
for other people to use.
I had dashboards with
graphs and stuff,
and I would share those
around in meetings.
But it was really just me.
So it wasn't really an
enterprise application.
But anyway, so I
discovered R and was
hooked immediately and was able
to do some really cool work.
But I was an island
in the organization.
And I think many of us who
use open-source software may
feel that way.
But slowly but
surely, other people
started asking me, well,
how did you do that?
Or that doesn't look like
an Excel chart or something
like that.
And at the same
time, my organization
started becoming, in
general, more quantitative.
Oppenheimer was-- and now,
it is part of Invesco--
is a money-management firm.
We manage portfolios of stocks
and bonds and whatever else.
But we were very much an
old-school, fundamental
analysis, which is great.
It just doesn't come at it
from the quantitative side.
It's a much more
touchy-feely type of thing.
And like the rest
of the industry,
we all started becoming
more interested in applying
computational power to huge
amounts of information,
because the price of
computation is going down.
The accessibility of huge
information was going up.
So it just was part
of a natural trend.
And I was more fluent
than the average portfolio
manager in my firm with
the techniques needed
to work with that data, because
of just my freelance work
with R. So I think
that helped me out.
That did not play a part
in my career advancement.
I don't want to
suggest that at all.
But I also happened
to advance further
in my career at
Oppenheimer, ultimately
becoming CEO for the last
five years of my stay there.
But I continued to
play around with R,
even though, I have to
admit, I was playing hooky
from my real job when I was
doing data-science work.
I would do analysis
of our funds, analysis
of our competitors' funds on
various types of performance
metrics and so forth.
But as CEO, that was not my job.
There were people I could
ask to do that work for me.
But that was a release
for me and a little bit
of an unwind for doing that.
But at the same time,
people in my organization
understood that I was very
sympathetic or receptive
to using these kinds of
tools in the organization.
And I was constantly
evangelizing about
or thinking about ways that
our organization could apply
more quantitative techniques
to upping our game
all across the business.
So people-- there
were other islands
around our company of people who
were using this kind of stuff,
whether it was R or
Python or other tools.
And they knew that I
was very much a champion
of those sorts of things.
What that allowed us to
do, from their standpoint,
practically-- it allowed
them to fast track permission
to use these tools or to get
software updates or things
like that, because as I
said, we all got to the point
where you couldn't just
install whatever the heck
you wanted on your computer.
So at least they
knew that the IT guys
were going to be sympathetic
to their requests.
And this is a dichotomy
I'm sure many of you
see in your organizations
all the time.
There's an inherent tension
between the high priests in IT
and the individuals
on their desks
who want to be free to use
these open-source tools.
And having leadership in
the organization understand
and sympathizing with
that is very important.
One of the great things
about Posit, of course,
is that Posit has evolved
to really facilitate
easing of that
tension, if you will,
by providing walled-garden
types of tools where
there can be auditing and
control of the versioning
of all the various
packages and languages
and so forth that people
have on their computers,
but also letting people
have access to those tools
and not be constrained
by a large bureaucracy
for every little thing
they want to use.
So I think Posit is doing
great work on reducing friction
in the enterprise.
So I like that.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: [INAUDIBLE]
ART STEINMETZ: So again, we
started using these tools more.
But here's the
other ironic thing.
So I'm an investment person.
And like I said, I would like
to use quantitative tools
to look at time series of
interest rates and stock prices
and correlations and
capital asset pricing model
metrics around investments
and stuff like that.
And while I was an
evangelist for this stuff,
the people that were getting
more excited about this
were not my fellow portfolio
managers and investment
analysts.
It was the guys in sales,
the people in sales
that were getting more
interested in this,
because like the
investment people,
they were getting
terabytes of data
from their
organizations, stuff that
would come through our CRM--
we used Salesforce--
or the advisors
who would sell our funds.
So we were the asset managers.
And then we would have
advisors or stockbrokers--
financial advisors-- who would
sell it to retail individuals.
And they, for a fee, would let
us see their customer data--
what people were buying,
what people selling,
whether they were buying more
growth stocks or value stocks
or whatever it is.
And our salespeople would find
those tools very valuable.
But it was a data dump.
It was a deluge coming
from different sources.
A lot of places, it
was unstructured data.
And even when it was structured,
the formats from Morgan Stanley
were different than the
formats from Merrill Lynch
and this kind of stuff.
But our salespeople-- they got
it sooner than our investment
people, that we can use
open-source data-science tools
to make some sense of this.
And even today,
they're the ones that
are-- at Invesco,
my former colleagues
at Oppenheimer, now at
Invesco-- are the ones pushing
the envelope on this, on the
distribution organization.
One of the things
that is a crazy thing
about the mutual-fund business
is, people buy mutual funds,
and then they
decide to sell them.
Maybe they need to
sell them because they
need the money for
other purposes,
someone dies and the money
gets distributed in the estate,
or the performance stinks and
people stop liking the fund,
and so they say they want out.
All of those things
trigger redemptions.
Now, the industry, overall, has
a background redemption rate
of about 25% a year.
That means, just to stay even
with how much money we manage,
we have to go out and resell
25% of our total asset base
every year.
So that's billions and
billions of dollars.
And the other crazy thing--
well, it's not crazy at all.
But we sell-- we pay
commissions to sales people.
So getting a dollar
is much more expensive
than keeping a dollar.
So we could drop a lot of
money right to the bottom line
if we could cut our
redemption rate.
So I sat down with
our salespeople.
That became a thing I was
really pounding the table about.
So they went, and
we put together
a data-science team of about
nine PhD data-analytics people.
And this was all coming
out of the sales budget.
They cheerfully
paid for all this.
And we started
looking at, how can we
reduce our redemption rate?
At that time, our
redemption rate
was running above the
industry average of about 27.
And the nice thing when
you're a big firm--
you can run A/B tests.
We tried different
kinds of interventions,
different kind of
marketing materials,
changed who we visited and how
much time we spent with people,
tried so many different things.
And we found out what
worked and what didn't work.
And if people want some of the
details, I can go into that.
But the bottom line
is that we were
able to cut our redemption
rate, in a couple years,
from 27% to 23%.
So again, that was
tens of millions
of profit dollars that
dropped to the bottom line.
And again, we were using R and
RStudio to do these redemption
control tests.
So it was just tremendous.
So--
That's amazing.
I remember seeing the blog
post where you mentioned that.
So I want to make sure to
go grab that and put it
into the chat for
everybody, too.
But something else I wanted to
ask you is, on the Hangouts,
we talk a lot about
best practices
for sharing our work
with executives.
And it's rare that we actually
have the executive here
on the call.
So as a former CEO,
I was wondering
if you have any
tips for all of us
on communicating with
executives and sharing our data
work with them.
ART STEINMETZ: Yeah.
Two key points.
One is, data visualization
is the most powerful way
to get a narrative
across quickly.
So spend time learning good
visualization techniques.
Even if you're a math
whiz and a coding whiz,
understand good visualization.
It's an aesthetic issue.
It's an art.
And there's lots of blogs.
There's lots of literature that
talk about good visualization
and bad visualization.
And don't use a
linear scale when
you should be using a log
scale, simple stuff like that,
because I've seen
so many bad charts.
And at worst, you're going
to lose your audience
very quickly.
Well, not necessarily
even at worst.
At best, maybe you're going
to lose your audience.
At worst, your audience will
draw the wrong conclusions
and make bad decisions.
Richard Feynman, the physicist,
was on the Challenger disaster
panel.
That was a space shuttle
that blew up on re-entry.
And one of the big
takeaways in that inquiry
was that PowerPoint
was to blame.
So the other point I
would make is, don't use--
and I learned this from
reading about the history
of that inquest--
is, don't use a
PowerPoint presentation
when you should be
using a memo that people
can read in a narrative,
because all of you
are familiar with the problem
of seeing a PowerPoint slide.
So you've got it
landscape orientation.
And you've got this
incredible amount of text on--
12-point-font text filling up a
slide, as if it's a slide deck.
And sometimes you're subjected
to sitting in a conference
room, having that thing with
2 minutes' worth of text
on a slide that you're
supposed to process.
Of course, nobody
looks at that at all.
And they're listening
to, hopefully,
what the speaker is saying.
But it's a complete
waste of everyone's time
to create and display
this giant PowerPoint,
this massive quantity of
text on a PowerPoint slide.
So don't use PowerPoint when a
pre-read memo would do the job.
And yeah, some people aren't
going to read the memo.
But treat your audience with
respect anyway and tell them
you're going to assume people
have read the materials.
And then if you're going to have
a PowerPoint or a slide deck,
have three, four bullet
points, most, on a slide.
And then have compelling
visualizations
that tell your story.
That's going to earn
you far more respect
than showing that you've
crammed your PowerPoint
with a million words.
Thank you.
That's really helpful.
I see Art-- or, let's see.
I think, Alan, you asked
a question a little bit
earlier in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah, sure.
Hi, everybody.
I'm curious, Art, if in finance
or in portfolio management,
if you have to be
concerned about things
like validated systems, software
quality, the sorts of things
we talk about here a lot
with regards to fina--
not finance, with the pharma
and med device and stuff.
Are there places in
the business where
you've got lots of landscape
to experiment with tools
and then other places where
there are folks doing work that
have to be much more diligent
about being validated or being
controlled?
And just because I don't
know anything about it,
are there enterprise
applications
that are made for purpose for
that specific kind of stuff,
or does every shop
have their own tools
that somebody made and
everybody just keeps using them?
Yeah, good question.
Like health care, finance is
a highly regulated industry,
particularly as you're
consumer-facing.
So we have enormous
amounts of regulations
over what we can say
to people and what
our responsibilities and
potential liabilities
are when we misrepresent
what we are saying to people,
like if you say, you
can't lose money.
This is a guaranteed win
or something like that,
to state the obvious.
But to your point, yes,
there is a huge problem,
in our industry,
around model risk.
And if we use any model--
and that's very liberally
defined, by the way--
to help us with our
investment decision-making,
and we come back at some point,
or it's disclosed somehow
that that model had a
coding error, a bug,
and gave an incorrect answer
because of a bug in the code,
strictly speaking, we are liable
for making investors whole
for any losses on that.
And there have been many
instances of lawsuits
around exactly that.
So we have to be
very, very careful.
And as you all know,
there's no such thing
as bug-free software.
There will be
errors and problems.
And it's incumbent on us to
self-report whether or not
that caused losses.
And the SEC has leveled
hundreds of millions
of dollars of fines, over the
last decade, to firms with--
for model errors.
And invariably,
whenever people lose
a lot of money in an investment
that someone else is managing,
there will be lawsuits.
So in 2008, there was the
great financial crisis,
and stocks went down.
Everything went down.
There were lots of problems.
And there were lots of lawsuits.
And the heart of many of
those were, I lost money,
and I'm mad about it.
I want somebody
to make me whole.
So now if I'm
hiring a lawyer, how
do I craft a case that
says it was somebody else's
fault, other than
just the market,
and I therefore
should be made whole?
One of the first things they
go looking for-- whether or not
there were models involved
in making the trades,
whether any robots
were doing the work.
And then were
there bugs in that?
So every model is different.
Every process is different.
There's no automated
way of saying,
is this bug-free, obviously.
But all the big accounting
firms will audit your models
if you pay them.
So that's what we had to do.
And between you and me, if
there was some subtle coding
error that switched a positive
sign to a negative sign
somewhere, they're not
going to discover that.
But nonetheless, that becomes
a legal defense that you say,
well, I had an auditor
review the code.
But it is a huge
issue in the industry.
That's really interesting.
Thanks.
I want to make sure
I go over to some
of the anonymous questions
that were asked, too.
And I just wanted
to remind everybody,
because I know I say it in the
beginning, and a lot of people
join after, if you
want to ask questions,
feel free to raise
your hand on Zoom.
Or you can put questions
into the chat here.
And then we also have the Slido,
where you can ask anonymously.
And we'll reshare that link
because I know you can't see it
after you've joined.
But one of the first
anonymous questions,
Art, was, how do we
help leadership-- say,
VP level-- really
understand what
it is so that they don't just
succumb to the buzzwords,
like AI, machine learning,
big data, for example?
Yeah.
Well, the buzzwords
aren't useless.
To the extent that a senior
leader in the organization
gets all excited about
AI and is worried
about being left
behind, then that
means they're going to give
you more support for your work.
They're going to listen to you.
And then since maybe I'm sitting
in my nice corner office,
and I'm just hearing
the buzzwords--
I'm like the boss in Dilbert
or something like that--
but if I'm willing
to listen, then you
can give me a
deeper understanding
of what's involved.
So I think the buzzwords
are your friend.
The important thing-- if it
creates any sort of urgency
or creates more opportunity
for data scientists
to elevate the
visibility of their work.
The most important
thing, though,
is, you have to be honest.
So when I, as the boss, call
you into my office and say,
I heard about this
ChatGPT thing.
Let's fire our entire phone
customer support people
and just turn it
over to ChatGPT,
you have to be honest about what
these things can and can't do.
And one of the things that--
this will never change.
This has been true since
the times of Hammurabi--
that subordinates will
come into the boss' office,
and they'll blow
sunshine up your skirt.
And avoiding that,
getting an environment--
and this is impor--
this is what the
bosses have to do,
what the leaders have to do--
is create an
environment of trust,
where people can deliver bad
news about what something can
and cannot accomplish
to the boss.
And they can't be afraid
of saying, sorry, Boss.
ChatGPT isn't the
be all and end all.
And again, I experienced
this firsthand.
If I would say, oh,
this sounds like fun.
Let's do it.
Or this looks like this
will be interesting.
Let's do it-- people will
start scrambling around
and try and do it because
the boss likes it.
And, well, on one
sense, I'll say, good,
because I'm the boss.
I'd like to have some
influence over what people do.
But you have to have
the courage to say, no,
this is not going to work,
if it's not going to work.
Thank you.
I really like that
reframing of, buzzwords
can be your friend,
as well, when
you're trying to get your point
across or highlight your work.
ART STEINMETZ: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Yeah.
Dave, I see you had asked a
question a bit earlier, too.
Do you want to jump in next?
Sure.
Thanks, Rachael.
Hi, Art.
This is Dave Shea from Posit.
The description you have of
your experience at Oppenheimer
I know is almost backwards
for a lot of financial firms
and definitely for
other big organizations.
This is data-science
excellence and opportunity
pushed from the top down.
A couple questions around that.
Have you had any success in
discussing, with your CEO
peers, this opportunity?
And have you won
them over to that?
And then on the other
side, for folks working up
the chain, what do you
think is a successful way
to convey that
opportunity upward?
Yeah.
Well, I think, like I said,
it was a different time then.
But the world has come
around to understanding
the power of big data.
Again, it's a buzzword, right?
Big data, data science.
And my alma mater,
Denison University,
has launched a whole
school around data science,
data analytics.
And it's a liberal-arts college.
I was a Russian
major in college.
But I think CEOs
today very much--
even if they don't
necessarily understand it,
going back to the buzzwords,
they think it's important
and they need to
pay attention to it.
So I don't see much
resistance to that.
It's funny, though.
Like I said, the investment
people in my organization,
to some extent, still
are very old-school.
They are very wary of
quantitative techniques
because they-- there are
many quant funds out there,
and some of them do great work.
We are fundamental investors.
So it's reading annual reports
and talking to management,
visiting the factories or
whatever it happens to be.
That's fundamental management.
We try to beat the market
doing better research,
in those lines.
And there was a
lot of resistance
to quantitative
techniques because--
we're fundamental.
We don't want-- we're not going
to let the robots take over.
Now, the argument I would make--
I did make-- to--
when I became chief investment
officer and then CEO,
the argument I would make
to the investment people--
and I was not going to push
anything down their throats.
I was trying to evangelize
to make them want to do this.
But I said to them, look, this
isn't about the robots taking
your jobs, or we're going to--
literally, that's what
they were worried about,
that we were just going
to make these quant funds,
because we had some.
We launched-- because
nobody would come around
on the fundamental side, we
launched some quant funds.
The argument I made, with
limited success, was,
look, I'm not talking
about getting rid of you.
I'm saying, you have been
digging ditches with a shovel
your whole career.
Now I come and
give you a backhoe.
You're not going to use it?
It's a force multiplier.
If you can apply these
quantitative tools to suddenly
process far more data than
you used to be able to,
it's making your analysts
far more efficient.
But like I said, in terms
of the rest-- other CEOs,
other people in
asset management,
everyone has come
around, I think, to that.
And so I would be interested in
hearing what other people say
about this, because
you folks are
more mid-career, early
career than I certainly am,
as retired.
You would probably
have a better sense
of the receptivity in your
organization to using more
powerful quantitative tools.
I noticed a few people
resonated with when you
said living on your own island.
So [CHUCKLES] a lot of people
were feeling that, too.
What I hope-- and again,
this worked to some extent
in my organization.
And it's happening right now
at Invesco, too, I should add.
People look over your shoulder
and say, wow, that is cool.
How do you do that?
Or, I see a way I could apply
what you're doing there.
So for instance, at
Invesco right now--
and this started
after I had left--
one of their folks,
again in sales,
has created a Shiny app that
if one of our customers,
which is to say our brokers,
shares their customers,
which is the end investor,
their portfolios with us--
what other funds they're
invested in, what other stocks
they're invested in, whatever--
we can run an analysis on that
to help them optimize
their tax situation--
when they should
take capital gains,
take capital losses,
what they should sell to
realize a loss or a gain,
and then if they want to
keep the portfolio complexion
the same, what should they then
buy on the other side to keep
the portfolio complexion--
the overall risk
or aggressiveness,
whatever it happens to
be-- the overall portfolio
complexion the same.
So he built a Shiny
app that does that.
So all of our salespeople,
all of Invesco salespeople,
can look at all of the advisors
that they serve and look
at that.
And that generates discussions.
And salespeople love
to have opportunities
to call their customers up and
have an interesting discussion
and say, look, here's
an issue you have
that I think I can
help you solve.
Salespeople love getting
that kind of a lead.
So it generates
that sort of thing.
And then if the discussion
goes further, with one click,
they generate a
detailed PDF report
on exactly what the
gains and losses are
across the portfolio.
And the salespeople
just love that tool.
But it's one individual.
And my fear is that
it dies with him.
If he leaves the firm, who's
going to maintain that?
It's an island.
And yet, it's a Shiny
app in production
that has become an
extremely popular tool
among 200 salespeople.
So it's an interesting
opportunity.
And this person is not naturally
a real outgoing, gregarious
individual.
So I've been trying to encourage
him to think about ways that he
can let other people know,
this is a tool that he built,
and you can have this kind of a
cool tool, also, in your area.
So getting him off
the island is--
I've made it a--
I have no vested
interest in this.
I've kind of made it my mission.
Absolutely.
It's really interesting to
think about, maybe some of us
could be targeting our work
to different groups of people
within the company, like
sales, which we may not
have thought of before.
And I see somebody had
asked an anonymous question.
That sales was so
interested in the data
was really interesting to them.
And they asked, were
there any groups
that you were surprised
weren't interested,
and why do you think that was?
Yeah.
Well, again, I've already told
the story about the investment
people.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Yeah.
ART STEINMETZ: And they
were pretty skeptical.
The other group, as well--
is it worth the cost?
What's the IRR on
this investment?
And again, in the anecdote
I shared about redemption
control, the IRR was
strongly positive,
but it's not always
going to be that way.
But I think it is important to
have a clear-eyed understanding
of what the IRR is going to
be on a project like this.
What I would not
be concerned about
is whether there
are enough projects
for a data-science team.
In most organizations, you
might have a particular use case
when you spin up some kind of
a data-science organization.
But like I said, very
quickly, other people
will see the cool stuff that
is happening and want in on it.
Oh, one of the questions I saw,
going back into the chat, was,
what books you might
recommend that help you
throughout your career
to develop your mindset
as a data-science CEO.
Well, let's see here.
I already talked
about Tufte, right?
So he's got a whole
bunch of books.
But this is the one that
started it all, The Visual Dis--
[INAUDIBLE]--
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I can see it.
ART STEINMETZ:
--The Visual Display
of Quantitative Information.
And this guy is kind of
a lovable curmudgeon,
kind of a crank.
But he's passionate
about making sure
that your visualizations
convey the information that you
want them to convey.
So his whole series
of books-- they're
all classics in the field.
Another one to pull off
the shelf that I think
is a ripping yarn
is Against the Gods
by Peter Bernstein, The
Remarkable Story of Risk.
For anyone who
wants to understand
how we went from thinking
everything is just
in the hands of the
gods, and it's all fate,
to being able to price
derivatives using
normal distributions and
understanding probability,
this is a great book.
And this is not
dry in the least.
But I think it's very
useful for understanding how
the history of risk evolved.
The ancient Romans were
inveterate gamblers,
but they had no
sense of probability.
So if you wanted
to go play cards,
play poker with the Romans,
you could really fleece them.
But it was Blaise
Pascal, who was
a philosopher and
mathematician, who
really developed probability.
And he did it because
he was a gambler.
So there's another book
that got me thinking about--
it's out of reach
because it's over
in my business-books section.
But there's another book called
The Outsiders by Richard--
his last name is Thorndike.
I'm not sure his
first name is Richard.
But he has a great
book for thinking
about how CEOs should
think about maximizing
the value of their businesses.
And that had a profound
influence on me.
One of the things that is true--
if you look at most mergers
of publicly traded companies,
the vast majority,
3 plus 3 equals
5, which is to say that
the mergers are usually
destructive of
shareholder value.
And I won't name names,
but I've experienced
this so often in my career.
And the problem is, the
CEO of the combined entity
now gets to say, I
grew the company.
It's much bigger now.
And he, of course-- he or she--
obviously, usually a white man--
is running a much
bigger organization.
And that could be used to
justify the board paying him
a lot more generous
compensation.
And he gets the
reputation as a dealmaker.
But the problem is, if the two
companies were worth 6 apart,
and they're now worth
5, you lost money.
You didn't do a good job.
This book, The Outsiders, really
cracks that open and does a lot
of-- as business
books like to do,
there's a lot of anecdotes
and case studies--
shows a few CEOs who understood
that and bucked that trend
and really thought
about how to grow
the wealth of their
shareholders, which
is what they're accountable to.
One of the things that--
whenever companies
get mashed together,
there's talk of
cost savings, right?
You have synergies, economies
of scale, et cetera.
And that's all well and good.
But there's hardly ever any
talk about revenue synergies,
because there
seldom are any, even
though there will be some
genuflecting in that direction.
So anyway, that
book, I thought, was
very formative in my
thinking as someone
who was running a
company, someone
who bought other companies,
and who ultimately sold
my company to another company.
I love this-- just grabbing
the books off the back.
It's like book
club with Art here.
[LAUGHTER]
This is--
I'm a book-- I have a fetish
b I fetishize them as objects.
And so I really like
sitting in my library
with a Manhattan in the
evening and reading a book.
Nice.
So I know something that
you are also really involved
with is enhancing data literacy
and mathematical literacy.
And you've been involved
with Rock The Street,
Wall Street, whose mission is
to equip girls with the skills
to succeed, and many
other organizations.
And I wanted to give
some time to talk
a little bit about that,
too, and see if there's
any that you'd recommend
we get involved in
or ways to get more involved.
Yeah, thanks for
asking that, because it's
obviously a worthwhile topic.
I don't have to
sell anybody here
on the value of being
data-literate or understanding
basic math.
But there's a weird cultural
problem I think we have,
certainly in this
country and maybe
in a lot of other countries-- is
that it's OK to be bad at math.
People are perfectly
happy, maybe
even proud, to say,
oh, I'm bad at math.
It's like-- no one says,
oh, I'm bad at reading.
Oh, I'm proud to be illiterate.
Numeracy should be
something that we all
are very proud of having.
And the consequences of not
being numerate are horrible.
And you see, in--
our country has become so
polarized, politically.
And the rhetoric that
goes back and forth--
so much of the
persuasive power of that
is grounded on people not
understanding numbers, I find,
and not being willing to--
and being very
skeptical of science,
being very skeptical
of experts, like those
are elites or something
like that, when all of you
probably went to college,
and you learn a lot of stuff,
and you went on to graduate
school or in your careers,
and you're very proud of being
an expert in your field and all
the knowledge you created.
And the idea that that just
should be devalued somehow
because people need to feel
good about being ignorant
is an unfortunate
state of affairs.
I wish we could
get back to a point
where knowledge is
respected in whatever field
that happens to be.
But certainly, one of the ways
to do that and make all of us
more successful in our
own lives is to make sure
that kids understand--
know that it's-- cool
is too strong a word,
but cool to know math and be
proud of having math skills.
And so I was involved with the
National Museum of Mathematics,
which--
their mission is
to make math cool.
And it's not a kids'
museum, by the way.
They have tons of kids
programs, and probably
most of the visitors to
the museum are children.
But it really shares the
wonder of mathematical concepts
at an adult level as well.
So if you're ever in Manhattan,
it's absolutely worth a visit,
because it's a very cool
exploratorium kind of museum.
It's just not definite integrals
printed on a poster on the wall
or something.
It's a very cool museum.
And one of the problems,
obviously, in poor communities,
underprivileged communities,
whatever word you
would like to describe them--
minority communities-- the
schools are generally poor.
And Rock The Street, Wall Street
brings a finance curriculum
into underserved schools,
using volunteers.
So the business model, if you
will, of Rock The Street is,
we get a corporate sponsor
and a corporate volunteer
from that sponsor.
And they teach a--
call it a finance
course, to kids.
And one of the purposes of
that is to get more girls--
because it is focused on
girls-- and I use the word girls
because this is high school--
get girls interested in
careers in financial services.
And while we know less
than half of the girls
actually go into
financial services--
but every single
one of them is going
to get out of this program
with basic financial literacy.
They are going to
understand that the credit
limit on your Mastercard
isn't an asset,
and paying 25% a year
in compound interest
on your credit-card balance is a
really bad problem to get into.
So those kind of basic issues
around financial life skills
is an important part
of what they do.
And of course, they go into
these less-served communities.
And one of the
things that just--
it breaks my heart, and why
I'm passionate about this-- is,
you've all heard this term
"the cycle of poverty."
And this cycle of ignorance
exists in these communities
as well.
And in many cases, obviously,
the family situation
is not a traditional
two-parent family.
And even when it
is, you have issues
where there isn't
respect for learning
in some of these families.
They say, why do you--
that's not for you.
You don't have a chance.
The system is
rigged against you.
Why bother?
And fighting against
familial culture,
in some cases, to give these
girls the belief that, yes, you
can achieve--
that doesn't mean the road is
easy, but this is possible.
And it just takes hard
work and learning,
and you can achieve that.
So Rock The Street does
great work swimming
against that tide of ignorance.
So it's been heartbreaking
to see some of this stuff,
but also so inspiring
to see the change
that it can make in
some kids' lives.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Absolutely.
So helping other--
whatever it happens
to be in helping kids
understand early on
that they can achieve,
that learning and knowledge
are valuable things
to have-- it seems crazy
to have to say that.
But girls, in particular,
are underrepresented--
or, women, in particular, are
very underrepresented in asset
management.
So that was one
of the things that
got me interested in Rock
The Street to begin with.
We need lots more representation
among people of color as well.
But women also are, again,
very underrepresented.
So that's just trying
to get a little more
inclusivity in finance.
But also, what Rock The Street,
in particular, recognize
is that girls self-select out
of STEM fields very early.
The cultural background is such
that women are told, explicitly
or implicitly-- girls
are told explicitly
or implicitly-- that
they're not good at math,
they're not good at science,
or that's not for them.
And again, it doesn't
have to be explicit.
But we find that they
self-select out of STEM
very early, in high school.
And that's why it's important
to-- there's lots of groups
that help give women
early career support.
Or, in college, there's
Girls Who Code, for instance.
That's more college level.
Getting down into
the high-school level
is critical because
of this problem.
Absolutely.
Thank you so much
for sharing that.
And I did put into the chat,
if there are other groups
that people are
involved with as well
and want to share in
the chat, please do.
I know that our time
goes by so quickly here.
Is it OK if I rapid-fire a
few questions at you, Art?
Thank you for listening
to me blab, folks.
We love it.
So one anonymous
question maybe touches
on things we've talked about.
But can you say, what's the
number-one reason you think,
whether it's financial
services or any company--
should move to open-source
languages, like R and Python?
Yeah, because
of the ecosystem.
With R or Python,
it's the packages
that will do anything you want.
And these packages, of course,
are constantly peer-reviewed.
There was a notion,
10, 15 years ago,
that commercial software was
better because you had people
who were paid to mind
it, whereas open-source,
anybody could do anything.
And who knows whether
the code is any good?
Which-- the truth was the
opposite of that, right?
When you've got a million
eyes on something,
errors are spotted
much more quickly.
Now, there were
commercial software firms
that had a vested interest
in perpetuating that notion.
[LAUGHS] There was a blog post.
It was taken down--
I guess it was SAS--
where they were ripping
open-source code.
And they made a very kind of
disgusting dig that could--
at Hadley Wickham.
They said, do you want
trained professionals auditing
your code, or do you want
some drunk guy in New Zealand?
[LAUGHS] Which I thought
could only mean Hadley.
Hadley is from New Zealand.
I have no idea whether
he enjoys liquor at all.
But why would they say that?
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: [LAUGHS]
It's ridiculous.
But it just shows the
nastiness that was out there.
But it's clear that the
huge ecosystem of packages
maintained by
passionate individuals
acting as a community is what
gives open-source its power.
I never saw that
blog post, but now I'm
interested to go and--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHS]
--because they didn't
leave it up for very long.
One other anonymous question
was, as a data person,
what are the best ways to
develop domain and business
knowledge?
They said, it benefits me to
talk with the business people,
but not systematically.
Yeah, that's kind
of a tough problem
because it requires you being
an advocate for yourself
in the organization.
And not all of us are
equipped to do that.
I wasn't.
My path to the top
of the organization
was very serendipitous.
And I'll spare you the
details on that as well.
But you need to be able to
get out there and advocate
for yourself.
So you have to show up and stick
your nose in when there are
discussions about the business.
And hopefully, you
can present yourself
as someone who is eager
to help solve problems.
If you say, look,
I'm here because I
want to understand the problem
so I can do better helping you,
however you want
to say that, that's
the kind of approach that
always worked with me when
people say--
because I certainly could have
no objection to someone who's,
say, in IT coming
around saying, I
want to understand
how you run money
better so I can understand
your needs better.
No one is going to say,
oh, get out of my face.
But it does require you getting
out of your comfort zone,
perhaps, and being an
advocate for yourself.
Definitely.
I just want to make sure I had
seen everybody's questions.
So feel free to
raise your hand here.
And Art, if you have to
run at the top of the hour,
just let us know.
I just want to give
people a last second.
[INAUDIBLE]
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: OK.
I'm going to go nuke my
Ramen when you're done.
All right.
OK.
So one question I
did want to ask you
before you go is, what is the
best career advice that you've
ever received?
You see, I'm not sure I could
say what the best advice is
[INAUDIBLE]--
It doesn't have to be best.
Maybe just something
that comes to mind.
ART STEINMETZ: [INAUDIBLE]
I don't like using
the word best, actually,
when I think about it.
[LAUGHTER]
It was just, don't look
to your career advancement.
Yes, you might be
an ambitious person.
But don't think about
everything in terms of,
how is this going to
advance my career?
Think in terms of how this will
help others in their career.
It's enlightened
altruism, if you
will, because if you gain a
reputation in your organization
for someone who is
boosting others,
that is going to grease
the skids for you
in a very powerful way.
And someone told me that once,
and it was absolutely true,
because no one likes that
guy who you know he's already
looking for his next job.
[LAUGHS] Well, thank
you so much, everybody,
for all the great questions.
And thank you so much,
Art, for joining us here.
This has been a blast.
Yeah, it was a lot of fun.
I appreciate it.
I hope the rest of you
enjoyed it as well.
Thank you so much.
I'm going to share your
LinkedIn here in the chat
so people know
where to find you.
Anything else you
want to leave us with?
Also, type in my-- my blog
name is ArtSteinmetz.com.
So they can--
Awesome.
I'm going to reshare that
again in the chat, too.
There we go.
Thank you so much, Art.
ART STEINMETZ: All
right, bye bye.
Have a great rest
of the day, everybody.